[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti pour le sommaire
basket en nationale 3 trappe devait
gagner pour rester dans la course à la
montée il est rapide selon emporté sur
le terrain de marly-le-roi sur le score
de 67 à 62 le résumé de la rencontre de
sauce cesser cette fuite sport foot us
coup de projecteur sur les templiers
d'elancourt les saint quentinois
reprennent la saison de deuxième
division ce week-end contre les léopards
de rouen pour recevront l'équipe dans ce
magazine
cyclisme le parcours officiel du paris
nice 2020 était dévoilée la semaine
dernière à versailles la course au
soleil s'élancera depuis plaisir le 8
mars prochain le lendemain depuis
chevreuse et détails dans quelques
instants
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du basket
trappe jouer ce week-end dans le
championnat de nationale 3 pour leur
reprise les trappistes se sont imposés
67 à 62 face à marly le roi le résumé du
match des images de mathilde de 2000 y
est un montage de jules grevy ville un
derby noir autour des vacances ce samedi
11 janvier marie leroy recevez trappe
pour le compte de la 12e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 sur la
première période trappe favori de la
rencontre domine et creuse l'écart
rapidement face au dernier du classement
le score à la pause 44 à 30
la première période est plutôt bonne
même si à la fin on peut quelques
erreurs et on leur permet de revenir un
petit peu mais la première période
allait aller pas parfaite parce que bien
sûr si jamais parfait mais on défend
bien on les empêche de jouer facilement
on met nos shoots à propos on arrive à
trouver nos intérieurs pendant la
première période
que mis à part deux joueurs qui étaient
prêts à jouer le reste était totalement
pas là clairement donc ben j'avais deux
joueurs sur 7
étant donné qu'on n'était que 7 ce soir
il ça fait déjà un peu et de prêt à
jouer sur l'espèce impossible mais la
vérité d'une première période n'est pas
forcément celle d'un match marly-le-roi
0 victoire depuis le début de la saison
grappy peu à peu son retard sur les
visiteurs mais le réveil des mares licha
est trop tardif les trappistes ont
remporté la victoire sur le score de 67
à 62 ans avant d'aller lé pour moi
catastrophique on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait on n'a pas défendu
on a pas on n'a pas respecté notre
équipe on n'a pas respecté l'adversaire
parce qu'on n'a pas joué à notre niveau
de jeu la deuxième période a été un peu
mieux parce qu'on a mis un peu de rythme
au début parce qu'on a défendu un petit
peu ce qu'on faisait pas sur la première
place et qu'on a posé quelques
difficultés sur nos rotations défensives
même si des fois on s'est laissé avoir
et
qu'on a trouvé de la civic et surtout
c'est ce qui nous a aidées et ce qui
nous a permis de revenir au classement
marly le roi est toujours dernier avec
zéro victoire en 12 matches de son côté
trappe remonte à la 4e place à seulement
un point de la deuxième place
la prochaine journée programmée ce
samedi 18 janvier marly-le-roi ira à
fécampoise et rap se rendra à rouen on
continue à parler à de basket les
féminines du chesnay versailles ont
enregistré une nouvelle victoire dans le
championnat de nationale 2 les filles de
vinko bardigues se sont imposés à 58 à
41 sur leur parquet contre flammes
carolos basket ardennes au classement
les yvelinois son troisième en embuscade
à seulement deux petits points de la
première place détenue par est escaudain
il y avait également du handball ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 2 féminine 10e journée
montigny le bretonneux s'est inclinée ce
week-end à domicile contre rennes
chantepie sur le score de 36 à 29
une défaite qui ne remet pas en cause
des ambitions du club pour cette année
2020 les jouets sont toujours dans le
top 5 du championnat on écoute le
président de la structure christophe
reding
les objectifs restent les mêmes que ceux
de début de l'année c'est à dire qu'en
fait c'est de figurer très très bien sur
la tête en fait du championnat national
2 avec l'objectif de donner c'est d'être
dans les toutes meilleures places
maintenant on a toujours les contraintes
des pectives de blessure c'est pour ça
qu'on fait au match par match et d'essai
que l'objectif suivant étant le match
suivant voilà avec une volonté en fait
de très bien figurer en fin de saison on
ouvre maintenant une page football
versailles se ressaisit après sa défaite
en 32e de finale de coupe de france les
versaillais se sont imposés 3 buts à 0
face à l'équipe 2 du paris saint germain
lors de la 13e journée du championnat de
nationale 3 au classement les joueurs de
la cité royale conserve la tête avec
quatre points d'avancé sur leur dauphin
ivry prochain match le 25 janvier sur le
terrain de créteil à luzy thanos on
continue à parler du paris saint germain
et d'une information insolite le club de
la capitale lance son jus de poids
artisanale les fouilles seront 100%
yvelinois elles proviendront de deux
vergers installé sur le futur centre m
d'entraînement du psg à poissy au total
2800 poirier de cette veille à variétés
différentes sont implantés sur 2 5
hectares
le bouteilles seront servis jusqu'à la
fin de la saison aux spectateurs des
espaces hospitalité au parc des princes
lui est un ancien joueur du paris saint
germain il ya joué de 2006 à 2015
clément chantôme trente deux ans a
décidé de poursuivre sa carrière à moins
de cinq minutes de son ancien son lance
un terrain d'entraînement du camp des
loges
le milieu de terrain s'est engagé avec
le club de poissy qui évolue en
nationale 2 en quatrième division
libre de tout contrat après son départ
du red star clément chantôme a signé
jusqu'à la fin de la saison
son objectif aider son nouveau club à se
maintenir l' espoir site actuellement
13e de son championnat
on va maintenant parler à tennis l'open
de la verrière a débuté ce week-end et
durera jusqu'au 2 février
sa 17e édition est une nouvelle fois
organisé au parc sportif philippe
cousteau de la ville les participants
viennent principalement des yvelines et
des départements limitrophes
il cherche à remporter à la fois la
dotation de 600 euros et bien sûr des
points en vue de leur saison les coûte
le président de l'as tu es la verrière
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est le premier tournoi de l'année
inscrit dans dans les tournois donc en
fin de compte c'est un rendez vous que
les gens connaissent surtout les jambes
des yvelines
donc on a beaucoup de gens qui y
viennent tous le tous les ans ils
reviennent inscrire un s'inscrire à ce
tournoi on voit maintenant parler rugby
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir a perdu un match important dans
la course au maintien les hommes de
sébastien roncalli se sont inclinés
contre les derniers du classement
l'heureux à l'extérieur score final 22 à
cette défaite est synonyme de surplace
au classement les plaisirs ou à vous
voir revenir l'avant-dernier orléans et
n'ont plus que trois points d'avancé sur
le dernier
prochain match dimanche prochain contre
eux à marcquois si plaisir va mal 2020
débute bien pour versailles dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 les versailles
et se sont imposés 33 19 à domicile au
stade de porchefontaine contre massif
central avec le bonus le bonus offensif
au classement les hommes de la cité
royale sont 4e à seulement quatre points
du podium
un dernier résultat à rugby dans le
championnat honneur l'union rugby centre
78 est une nouvelle fois inclinés daria
un domicile les saint-quentinois ont
perdu 24 à 22 face à vitry n'ont plus
gagné depuis le 16 novembre
malgré cette défaite et cette mauvaise
série
verser 68 reste dans le top 5 de la
division ont continué par du football
américain c'est la reprise pour les
templiers à d'elancourt les élans
courtois joueront ce week-end dans le
championnat de 2e division contre les
léopards de roi pour nous parler de
cette rencontre et des objectifs du club
pour cette nouvelle saison nous recevons
sur ce plateau nicolas à cambron
vice-président des templiers ainsi que
stéphane tavares joueurs u19 et ganis
soumare joueurs seniors bonsoir
messieurs
alors comment vous sentez-vous à l'aube
de cette nouvelle saison on sent bien
début de saison a bien démarré sur mois
de septembre c'est vraiment la phase où
on met on est dans le structurant donc
toutes les sections qu'elle soit sur la
partie football américain ou cheerleader
aujourd'hui bien démarré on a bien
structuré et voilà je pense que sur le
début de saison on est confiant yanis
vous êtes confiant également pour le
début de saison en bout on est confiant
là on a eu quatre mois pour se préparer
donc physiquement on est au top
on a pu mettre en place notre attaque
notre défense ça continue de se
coordonner et on a eu la chance d'avoir
des entraînements et des matches amicaux
avec des équipes de division supérieure
pendant la pré-saison donc ça nous a
permis de donner un peu plus de
confiance
quatre mois c'est un petit peu long
maintenant on a hâte de commencer cette
saison
comment se sont déroulées justement ces
matches amicaux alors donc on a eu deux
matches amicaux 1 contre une division 3
donc le premier qui était plutôt
compliqué début de pré saison on connaît
pas trop l'équipe donc on a du mal à lui
on a eu du mal à se coordonner au début
très vite on a pris le fil
ça s'est plutôt bien passé pour notre
deuxième match d'accord contre les
molosses d'asnières de division 1
donc ça de sape sur n'a pas permis de
nous repérer par rapport
une équipe qui a un niveau d'une
division au dessus donc voilà on a
réussi à dérouler comme il le fallait
donc ça nous a donné confiance en nous
et normalement il n'y a pas de souci
pour la saison on va parler de cette
rencontre contre les léopards qui est
favori sur cette rencontre
à votre avis les sinistrés alors il pour
l'aca il n'y a pas vraiment de favori en
fait donc on est deux équipes qui avons
tous les deux performer en division 1
antérieurement
on se connaît pas l'un l'autre on n'a
jamais joué l'un contre l'autre et on
n'a pas beaucoup d'informations pour les
léopards de rouen donc on verra bien à
partir du jour numéro en a pas de vidéo
l'équipe qui fait la moindre erreur on
va y aller on va dérouler notre jeu
comme on l'a fait pendant la pré-saison
et puis on verra bien nous on y va avec
dans l'optique de gagner
donc pour nous mais favori maintenant à
voir ce terrain qu'est ce qu'on craint
de plus sur une première rencontre de
championnat sur une première rencontre
on sait pas parce attendant le manque
d'automatismes peut-être c'est en fait
c'est compliqué dans une équipe de
football américain de
c'est l'équipe qui arrive à se réparer
le plus vite en fait on a 4 mois de pré
saison
une attaque c'est dur à mettre en place
donc faut une connexion cette commission
c'est ça qu'on cherche pendant la
pré-saison et si on arrive le premier
jour avec une bonne connexion pas besoin
d'ajustements on arrive on déroule un
gain stefan kuhn qui est en u19 qui est
ce qu'on apprend le plus justement sur
sur un début de saison et notamment sur
un début de saison au mois de janvier
forcément les conditions ne sont pas les
mêmes que pendant l'été ou au printemps
ce qu'on attend c'est surtout de bien
préparer notre île on a eu tout là aussi
zen pour préparer et on a beaucoup de
nouveau beaucoup de recrues on a un
coaching staff qui a réussi sa femme
boulot et beaucoup de nouveaux coaches
surtout deux américains qui induit
d'arriver dans ce mois ci janet années
comme hans et jay jay reddick et ils
vont se reformer le joueur après notre
objectif c'est de gagner plus de matchs
possible d'aller en playoffs alors
finale et la gagner
justement le choix des américains se
porte plutôt sur le staff cette année
plutôt que sur les joueurs
si je comprends bien loin des deux
monnaies templiers d'elancourt on a
donné à michael une grande dimension
assure la partie formation que ce soit
la formation évidemment des joueurs et
l'accompagnement des joueurs évidemment
dans la construction si des cheerleaders
avec la création d'une section junior et
puis la formation des arbitres toute la
partie encadrement en fait une structure
forte en fait sur la partie
d'encadrement et un effort particulier
en fait sur la formation avec
l'accompagnement évidemment deux joueurs
seniors qui viennent renforcer en fait
les dispositifs pour transmettre le
savoir c'est finalement une des valeurs
des templiers est ce qu'un jour comme
stéphane pour intégrer l'équipe senior
dès cette année ou un peu plus tard
ayvaz il est encore un petit peu de
temps et stéphane et on va lui laisser
un tout petit peu de temps ils
démontrent déjà de très belles choses
longue vie à lui sur la partie
footballistique mais laissons lui un peu
de temps yanis quels sont les objectifs
du club cette saison
alors l'objectif clairement ça fait
quatre ans si vous êtes en deuxième
division est ce que vous comptez
remonter cette année alors on a un petit
peu marre du chômage en division 2 donc
clairement tous les ans on vient avec
l'idée de monter en division 1 donc
cette année c'est pareil on cherchait à
monter clairement des objectifs de cette
année c'est de gagner tous les matches
si on gagne tous les matches on est
champions donc on va les entendre ils
ont entamé un parent et un par un on va
faire en sorte de gagner ce premier
match est capital
ça peut marquer les esprits
si on arrivait qu'on arrive à à deux
volets notre niveau de jeu et qu'on
gagne contre une équipe qui descend de
division 1 on pourrait envoyer un
message à la division 2 et ça pourrait
être important mais jusqu'à présent on a
fait des répétitions en fait donc six à
sept phases depuis le mois de septembre
là c'est pour ça que évidemment tout le
monde attend on va faire beaucoup plus
humble que la même prestation sur ce
plateau il ya un an où on allait dit on
avait dit qu'on allait tout déchirer en
effet on est un peu plus humble dessus
et on va regarder ce que ça va donner
justement on va terminer par un petit
pronostic petit pronostic pour ce début
de saison on a stick je serai pas un
50,0 j'espère que ça sera bien plus mais
mais non je rigole je rigole pour les
autres équipes et par le respect sur des
autres équipes évidemment les templiers
gagnant est évidemment j'attends
beaucoup moins de ce premier match en
fait pour vous stéphane principe combine
sa voix une victoire après le plus haut
possible en tant que supporters et yanis
un pronostic
bon moi je partirai pas sur un 50 0 me
en tout cas une victoire je connais pas
les léopards de haut un anarcho laisser
l'équipe qu'on affrontait mais une
victoire en tout cas ça c'est sûr au
lendemain j'espère
après on verra merci à tous les trois
avaient passé sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite une bonne saison 2020 et
surtout beaucoup de victoires un sans
faute peut-être un mot de cyclisme à
présent c'est désormais une tradition
divine la course cycliste paris-nice
passerait une nouvelle fois par le
département au mois de mars cette année
ce sont les villes de plaisir et de
chevreuse qui ont été choisie comme
ville départ des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude à une 78e édition du
paris-nice une nouvelle fois au départ
du 78 la course au soleil s'élancera
depuis le départ
des civils pour la onzième année
consécutive lors de chaque rendez vous
les organisateurs doivent se renouveler
et créent de nouveaux tracés objectif
surprendre les spectateurs depuis onze
ans on voit quand même pas mal de choses
les trois dernières années encore
davantage de choses quand les conditions
atmosphériques climatique s'y met avec
du vent on voit en convoi d'été bordure
on voit tout un tas de tout un tas de
choses donc c'est ça le vélo aujourd'hui
donc il faut absolument qu'on trouve
nous organisateurs des terrains de jeux
et les yvelines nous offre la
possibilité donc de mettre en place ces
terrains cette année la ville de plaisir
a été choisi comme terrain pour
accueillir la première étape de cette
édition 2020 le départ sera donné le
dimanche 8 mars de plus la commune
le peloton fera une boucle de 154 km à
travers les yvelines en passant par ben
montfort l'amaury ou encore
neauphle-le-château une satisfaction
pour plaisir qui a attendu de nombreuses
années avant d'être ville départ de
l'épreuve
ça nous ferons les chaque année mais
cette fois ci c'est vraiment bien
installé surtout que le village va être
dans le parc du château qui est un lieu
de rassemblement familial est un lieu de
rassemblement festif pour l'ensemble de
la ville
donc voilà on attendait que ça le
lendemain ses chevaux aux moins de 6000
habitants qui accueillera le départ de
la deuxième étape vers le loiret et des
stars internationales comme julian
alaphilippe o'hagan bernal la commune
sera la 19e ville des yvelines à être
village départ de l'épreuve chevaux est
considéré par les spécialistes comme une
terre de cyclisme
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit qui est
particulièrement prisée des amateurs de
vélo
beaucoup de professionnels aussi qui
viennent faire leur pré saison et leur
mise en route en ce moment d'ailleurs
sur les routes de la vallée de chevreuse
donc c'est un endroit qui s'y prêtent
vraiment et que je pense ce cycliste
apprécié l'histoire d'amour entre les
yvelines et le paris nice n'est pas
prête de s'arrêter le partenariat qui
devait s'achever en 2021 devrait être
reconduit cette année pour quatre
nouvelles éditions supplémentaires le
paris-nice passera donc par chevreux et
par plaisir cette année nous avons
profité de cette conférence de presse
pour rencontrer françois lemarchand le
directeur de cette course au soleil
cela fait onze ans que le paris-nice pas
ici depuis les yvelines à mes côtés
françois lemarchand le responsable de
course de paris nice
est ce qu'on arrive à se renouveler
après ses 11 années consécutives dans
les yvelines françois marchand mais se
renouveler c'est obligatoire le niveau
du cyclisme international s'élève et
puis il nous il faut qu'on trouve des
terrains de jeu d'autres terrains de jeu
et dans les yvelines nous avons ce
terrain de jeu entre les yvelines et
nice il ya des terrains de jeu donc on
renouvelle constamment c'est le terrain
de jeu idéal on peut le dire les
yvelines abel terrain de jeu idéal parce
que depuis depuis onze ans on voit quand
même pas mal de choses les trois
dernières années encore davantage de
choses quand les conditions
atmosphériques climatique s'y met avec
du vent on voit on convoi des bordures
on voit tout un tas de tout un tas de
choses ce que les jeunes du vélo espère
voir à la télévision parce que on a
quand même des belles images
donc c'est ça le vélo aujourd'hui donc
il faut absolument qu'on trouve nous
organisateurs des terrains de jeux et
les yvelines nous offre la possibilité
donc de mettre en place c'est justement
la météo est plutôt capricieuse 1 au
mois de mars dans les yvelines
il ya souvent eu du spectacle dans les
années passaient souvent eu du spectacle
nous on fait ce qu'il faut pour qu'ils
aient de la pluie parce que l'on croise
les doigts ou non mais le le
malheureusement ou heureusement pour
nous organisateurs quand il fait beau et
bien ça nous fait de la belle course
pour les coureurs discutailler découvrir
tout à l'heure donc les coureurs y
lisent ils préfèrent pas de vent pas de
pluie du soleil et on va tout doucement
tranquillement et gentiment jusqu'à nice
mais non quelque part pour le pour notre
sport les images sont fabuleuses quand
on voit des groupes partout des groupes
qui reviennent des favoris seront figées
c'est ça le cyclisme on va revenir sur
cette première étape à plaisir pourquoi
plaisir pourquoi le choix de plaisir pas
le choix de plaisir en ce moment
convention avec le département donc ma
tous les ans on a une nouvelle ville
plaisir on pouvait faire un départ et
une arrivée surtout surtout une arrivée
avait également un départ mais le
problématique c'est elle s'était trouvée
assise t'arriver pouvoir installer
toutes les installations et technique
toute la partie technique donc c'est ce
que nous avons fait et après ont agi de
désigner le parcours tout autour cherché
toute hâte en difficulté donc on a
réussi à mettre ce qu'on voulait en
oeuvre vous allez passer par quelques
communes on va passer par mollo va au
début on va faire une grande boucle on
va passer par poignées des forêts
montfort l'amaury mais après on va on va
tourner vers crêpier affaires moule
remonter toutes les petites côtes
le lendemain le peloton s'élancera
depuis chevreuse chevreuse un petit
village de 6000 habitants c'est un petit
peu ça aussi l'essence du paris-nice
chaque année il ya une petite commune
des yvelines qui est mise en avant
vous plaidez de communes qui est mise en
avant donc nous au niveau aux structures
à ceux des structures sont beaucoup
moins imposante prenez le départ et
d'aller à chevreux c'est parfait parce
que je suis heureux c'est un peu paradis
du vélo c'est un peu le cyclisme des
cyclistes qui roulent tous les dimanches
voir toute la semaine donc c'est un peu
l'histoire du vélo qu'est ce que vous
voulez me parlait tout à l'heure du
grand prix des nations ont gagné par
jacques anquetil qui se déroulait dans
la vallée de chevreuse donc pour nous ça
nous rappelle un petit peu les souvenirs
et c'est parfait que le départ soit de
swatch heureuse
pas très loin des hôtels ou les eu
toutes les équipes seront hébergés donc
pour nous c'est important c'est
principal merci françois lemarchand les
passionnés de heath porte avait
rendez-vous à jouy en josas oic l us jj
football organisé la troisième édition
de son tournoi fifa sur consoles de jeu
ce samedi 11 janvier un événement ouvert
cette année exclusivement aux jeunes
jusqu'à à 15 ans la formule était simple
des matches de poule puis les rencontres
à élimination directe des huitièmes
jusqu'à la grande finale comme à la
coupe du monde
au total 26 participants sont venus à
tâter les manettes au centre sportif et
associatif de jouy en josas un tournoi
remporté par matisse goursolle trois
victoires en trois éditions pour lui
propos recueillis par grégory à cannes
et on en organise ce genre d'événement
pour
pour ce faire connaître seul coup dans
un premier temps et ensuite j'ai eu
beaucoup de retours des parents qui sont
super contents de voir qu'on organise
des événements entre plusieurs
catégories
on a des plus jeunes jusqu'aux jusqu'au
jusqu'au 14 ans donc ça permet aux
enfants de connaître les enfants des
autres catégories aussi c'est ça permet
aux parents de se connaître
donc ça permet de mettre une bonne
ambiance au sein du club on passe
maintenant notre page agenda on va
parler dans cet agenda d'un cross qui
aura lieu le 2 février à prochain le
cross de la sablière l'eau rendez-vous
fêtera cette année sa 39e édition au
départ de viroflay pour nous parler de
cet événement nous recevons sur ce
plateau jean pierre rouyer président de
l'ue sm viroflay organisateur ainsi
cantona bortolotti à 19 ans bonsoir
bonsoir
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter l'historique de cette course
j'entrerai louis le coz la salle lire et
écrire me sanson 17 par bernard serena
riz prison au nord de le smv son équipe
et dès le départ le corps de la sablière
à être un très gros succès populaire et
donc il est organisé tous les ans depuis
cette époque là c'est l'une des plus
anciennes courses à un des yvelines on
va voir là une justement de nos
confrères des nouvelles de versailles
c'était lors du deuxième cross de la
sablière 1978 cross à laquelle le nom de
participer à l'époque et m'a forcément
j'étais un peu plus jeune qu'aujourd'hui
et donc du coup j'ai toujours eu ce qui
était à viroflay de perpétrer le spp le
creux de la sablière un événement festif
au coeur de l'hiver
c'est toujours le même parcours depuis
depuis les bidons même depuis le départ
il ya eu trop quatre départs qui ont été
programmés il ya eu plusieurs parcours
aujourd'hui on parle depuis las on
appelle la piste à viroflay et on part
immédiatement forêt pour un parcours
entièrement forestier alors plusieurs
courses sont au programme 1 6 km 1 11 km
et trois courses pour les enfants
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus oui mais il y aura toujours
trois courses pour les enfants et de
plus en plus d'enfants aujourd'hui parce
qu'effectivement il a de plus en plus de
clubs des yvelines qui vont nous
rejoindre sur les petites catégories
et sur le crucial du ltte gars aussi des
nouveautés puisque les allemands dassler
nos villes jumelées vont venir courir
c'est damir indienne de coureurs
inscrits d'ores et déjà et est bien sûr
aussi toujours les sportifs en situation
de handicap que nous accueillons avec
les geôles est et les associations qui
les accompagnent
antonin vous serez sur quelques courses
de votre côté au départ dont 6 km le 10
février
alors c'est une course qui est vraiment
très très passionnant parce qu'on se
retrouve avec de nombreux amis on l'a
fait depuis petit donc on s'est vus
grandir on a évolué au fil des années on
a changé de cours c'est aujourd'hui 11 6
km c'est un peu une tradition à viroflay
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de
cesser complètement une tradition en
fait c'est une course très populaire
comme le dit jean-pierre et donc ça
réunit vraiment toute la population de
viroflay il alors la compétition se
déroule principalement entre la fraude
moudon et versailles est ce que c'est un
terrain compliqué donc il y avait
l'habitude de faire ce cross c'est un
terrain qui est assez technique en fait
il faut quand même bien s'entraîner sur
de la forêt parce qu'il ya de nombreuses
montées de nombreuses descentes et bien
sûr l'ingrédient indispensable à tout
bon cross c'est la boue donc il faudra
être prêt et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'on organise des des journées de
reconnaissance les deux dimanches
précédant le cross pour venir opérer
parcours vous êtes d'accord
c'est un parcours compliqué bruit c'est
un parcours ça m'a compliqué à pas mal
de blessés de parcours qui fait la
renommée de ce cross oui il en aura
dépensé l'environnement aussi
tout le monde est content tout le monde
aime cet environnement l'enterrement
forestier c'est assez rare aujourd'hui
et donc grâce à lonay fonds peut avoir
effectivement des conditions quand même
deux parcours assez idéal sur des grands
chemins
alors ce sera le 2 février prochain ce
qu'il vaut mieux avoir un terrain 7 ou
un terrain humide
bah je crois qu'on n'a pas le choix
c'est la météo qui décide nr il a fait
un temps splendide de printemps
peut-être cette année sera le contraire
mais bon je pense que ce sont le
parcours sera de toute façon humide
contenu fait qu'on est au coeur de
l'hiver en tenant ces insectes avant
humide
qu'est ce que vous préférez or nous on
espère qu'il y aura de la boue parce que
c est vraiment l'élément du
cross-country on espère voir patauger un
petit peu et voir prendre beaucoup
plaisir parce qu'elle est blessures
parfois sur ce type de manifestation
non c'est assez rare mais je pense que
les gens en général sont assez bien
entraîné mais bon c'est un sport
forcément sans contact donc c'est
relativement rare
justement sur les journées
d'entraînement est ce qu'il faut
absolument venir en reconnaissance pour
participer à ce cross bien sûr il est
préférable si on connaît le parcours à
l'avant ce sera plus facile le jour j
mais après sinon on peut s'entraîner soi
même de son côté juste à découvrir un
petit peu sur le terrain de la forêt
pour pouvoir connaître et avoir de
meilleurs appuis lors de la course soit
un gros entraînement ou pas oui bien sûr
parce que 7ème du cardio donc le
parcours est quand même assez sélectif
il ya du dénivelé il ya aussi une
distance 5 est importante
il alla bout c'est quand même quelque
chose de fatigue ans donc je pense qu'il
faut pas sache seuls 60 s'engager dans
une telle manifestation sans
entraînement et d'ailleurs certains pour
laquelle on demande ainsi le cas médical
pour les adultes
qu'est ce qu'on gagne ah ben il est en
gagne comme d'habitude des très belles
médailles pour les enfants le t-shirt
finisher pour les adultes
et puis bon il ya forcément
effectivement les récompenses le goûter
à l'issue de la manifestation et bien
sûr après pour tous les bénévoles parce
que je pense que c'est important a
insisté aussi sur leur présence parce
que chacun est responsable et une
soixantaine de bénévoles le jour de la
compétition et donc ils entendront pour
ensemble le repas des bénévoles à
l'issue de manifestations pour clôturer
la journée festive dans la question
comment fait pour s'inscrire via
internet
oui ces terres est on s'inscrit points
comme cross de la sablière ou
éventuellement par courrier au siège du
club
et enfin les inscriptions jusqu'au
dernier moment au siège du club le
samedi et sur place aussi le dimanche
matin jusqu'à un quart d'heure avant le
début de chaque course
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau je vous rappelle à du 39e
cross de la sablière ce sera le 2
février prochain au départ de viroflay
et on termine par un rendez vous foot
ball trap reprend la compétition ce
week-end les trappistes vont affronter
ozoir à l'extérieur à l'occasion de la
11e journée du championnat de régionale
2 un gros morceau pour le est rappelée
joueurs de seine-et-marne sont
troisièmes du classement les ivy moi
luttent eux pour le maintien si vous
voulez les soutenir l'entrée est libre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]